there always seems to be room for a few
more bad guys in the marvel cinematic
universe and if the mcu is going to
introduce a few more villains next time
around
here's how they could expand to include
some of their best and weirdest comics
bad guys in avengers 4.
one of the most interesting aspects of
infinity war is that thanos's infamous
snap of the fingers straight up killed
people rather than erasing them from
existence
that means there are a lot of
superheroes in that world who are dead
and since it stands to reason that at
least a few of them will make it back to
the land of the living
that means that they've got to be
somewhere else in the meantime
that opens up the possibility of
introducing mephisto the marvel
universe's most prominent take on the
devil
there are even connections that are
already waiting to be explored
mephisto's role as a bargainer means
that he could be in a perfect position
to trade something for the heroes lives
we know from dr strange that tony stark
staying alive is necessary for the
heroes to win
so maybe there's something tony has that
mephisto wants
maybe captain america is going to strike
a deal to bring back his two best
friends
or considering that mephisto was the one
who drove nakia to become a supervillain
in the comics by exploiting her love her
t'challa
maybe she'll be the one who has to make
a sacrifice to bring the black panther
back from the dead
there's another fun piece of the finger
snap it's not just earth that's affected
it's explicitly mentioned several times
that thanos is killing half the universe
which means that all of those
space-faring societies that we've seen
in the guardians of the galaxy movies
have also been hit
that leaves outer space weakened and
destabilized on a cosmic scale
making it the perfect time for a galaxy
conquering super villain to show up and
start destroying things
and there's no one better for that role
than a nihilus in the comics he's
essentially a sentient space locust hell
bent on devouring
everything in his path across the galaxy
since thanos has apparently retired to a
farm at the end of infinity war
temporarily shifting the focus to a more
vicious thread could be a good way to
show how big the stakes have gotten
half the universe dying is bad but it's
better than the other half being wiped
out by a dude who calls himself the
living death
if the mcu is looking to introduce a
villain that could rival thanos
then they might decide to go with one of
the greats dr doom
decades of stories where he fights iron
man doctor strange and even spider-man
have shown us that he's adaptable and
powerful enough to pose a threat to
anyone
including thanos himself he's even one
of the few villains to team up with the
heroes in the original infinity gauntlet
story and has had designs on the stones
more than a few times in the years since
of course there's an obvious sticking
point here despite his career of
fighting the whole marvel universe
doom will always be the arch nemesis of
the fantastic four
and the film rights to those characters
were held by fox
with the news that disney was buying out
fox and getting those rights back
however the ff could eventually find a
home in the mcu
it's pretty much inevitable although
kevin feige has said that there are only
vague ideas about how to bring those
characters into the mcu
and that the next few movies including
avengers 4 were set in stone well before
the buyout
while it's tempting to focus solely on
massive cosmic threats
there's plenty of room for more minor
villains to step into the spotlight
and take advantage of the chaos that
results from half the population of a
planet turning to dust
believe it or not that makes avengers 4
the perfect opportunity to introduce the
jackal
best known as the villain directly
responsible for the infamous clone saga
peter parker is one of the characters
who gets dusted by thanos
meaning that there's currently no place
for one of marvel's flagship characters
in the next film
there are ways around that of course
homecoming already hinted at the
existence of miles morales
but they could always decide that a
clone of peter is a good way to go
if that seems unlikely consider this in
the comics the jackal is miles warren
who was one of peter's college
professors before he got obsessed with
cloning spider-man and gwen stacy
she's never named in the film but if you
look at the credits for homecoming
you'll find that orange is the new
blacks salinas leyva plays a teacher
named miss warren
maybe it's a coincidence over the mcu
you never know
one of the more unexpected moments of
infinity war involved a reappearance
from the red skull as a cosmic harbinger
of doom
since he's captain america's
arch-nemesis it makes sense that he
would somehow find his way back into
action
but now it seems that brock rumlow aka
crossbones is going to be back in
avengers 4 in some way too
at this point that could mean anything
from a flashback sequence to a scene in
the afterlife
but it could also mean that we'll be
seeing characters returning from the
dead who weren't just snapped into dust
if that's the case then why stop at
skull and bones why not go
all out with the whole dang skeleton
crew admittedly mother knight and
minister blood aren't exactly going to
set the world on fire
but they're no more or less well-known
than proxima midnight and corvus glaive
so hey why not finally we have the
character who's quite possibly the most
marvel comics of all the marvel villains
modoc
the mental organism designed only for
killing the mcu has gotten weird enough
that we've seen etre the dwarf
the grand master and a cameo appearance
from beta ray bill
arnhem zola has been in two movies and
while he admittedly never appeared in
his true comic book form as a big robot
dude with a tv
face in his chest winter soldier brought
him pretty close
so why not follow up the biggest and
most devastating superhero movie of all
time by throwing in the mental organism
designed only for killing
he's not the giant head in a flying
rocket chair that we want
he's the giant head in a flying rocket
chair that we need